[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 15 juillet voici
les titres de cette édition les centres
de vaccination yvelinois saturé depuis
quelques heures les dernières annonces
du président de la république ont
provoqué un pic sur le site d'octo libre
pour prendre rendez-vous les créneaux
sont désormais disponibles seulement à
la fin du mois avoir en août
le point à suivre le variant delta et
hylas 1 repris à un frein à la reprise
économique en attendant de connaître la
réponse focus dans cette édition /
france relance le plan a été lancé en
septembre dernier par le gouvernement
100 milliards d'euros pour faire
repartir l'économie quel déploiement
depuis dans les yvelines reportages et
invités géhanne benz élira sous préfète
qui sera avec nous pour parler de ce
sujet et puis retour sur les festivités
du 14 juillet dans les yvelines au
départ de la base de vélizy-villacoublay
la patrouille de france qui a participé
au traditionnel défilé aérien nous avons
pu nous glisser dans les coulisses de la
préparation
c'est à la fin de ce journal est du
sport également à suivre dans cette
édition avec la ville de mantes la jolie
qui accueille en ce moment les
championnats de france juniors d'aviron
[Musique]
comme je veux le leader je vous le
disais dans les titres depuis
l'allocution du président de la
république lundi soir c'est la ruée sur
les centres de vaccination contre le coc
vie de 19 partout en france
rien que sur la journée de mardi 1,3
million de rendez vous ont été pris sur
le site d'octo libre qu'en est-il dans
les yvelines et quels sont les centres
de vaccination qui vont rester ouverts
cet été ont fait le point avec eléonore
sinoquet difficile de trouver un créneau
disponibles pour la vaccination dans les
yvelines
en ce moment c'est la conséquence de
l'allocution du président de la
république lundi 12 juillet dernier
emmanuel macron a en effet annoncé le
passage à la vaccination obligatoire
pour l'ensemble des soignants mais aussi
l'extension du pass sanitaires pour
profiter des lieux culturels ou encore
des restaurants dès cet été
comme partout en france les centres de
vaccination y vit noah n'ont pas échappé
à la ruée vers la piqûre dans les
vaccinodromes de mantes-la-jolie et du
centre commercial vélizy 2 tous les
rendez vous sont pris jusqu'à fin
juillet alors que la semaine dernière il
était encore possible de s'y prendre
seulement quelques jours à l'avance au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines transformer en
vaccinodromes même combat
depuis lundi aucun rendez vous n'est
disponible avant la mi-août ce jeudi 15
juillet ce ne sont pas moins de 2300
personnes qui ont été vaccinées dans ce
centre dont 250 personnes sans rendez
vous le vaccine romands enregistrent
depuis lundi entre 350 et 400 injection
par heure au lieu de 300 habituellement
cet été s'ils restent ouverts ce ne sera
qu'à mi-temps de 8 heures à 14 heures
cinq jours par semaine
en revanche l'organisation la sueur elle
va densifier le nombre de vaccinés à
l'heure outre le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines trois autres
centres de vaccination reste aussi
ouvert tout l'été le centre commercial
vélizy 2 saint germain en laye et mantes
la jolie pour les autres centres encore
ouverts comme celui de versailles par
exemple ils fermeront leurs portes pour
la période estivale du 31 juillet au 22
août inclus
excepté ceux de chatou bonnières sur
seine et rambouillet qui se ferme d
fini tivement leurs portes si la prise
de rendez vous n'est pas disponible
il reste une dernière solution pour se
faire vacciner les opérations éphémère
organisées dans le département cet été
d'abord ce vendredi 16 samedi 17 juillet
à la base de loisirs de verneuil sur
seine puis sur les aires d'autoroute de
morainvilliers les 23 et 24 juillet
enfin entre le 30 juillet et le 4
septembre dans lé quartier des mureaux
et du 24 au 26 août aux centres sociaux
de carrières sous poissy 1 mais t es
deux vaccinations donc dans les yvelines
seul moyen d'obtenir le précieux sésame
le pass annie terre pour la rentrée et
ça a été dit dans la chronique des
opérations éphémère de vaccination
seront mises en place cet été également
dans les îles de loisirs elle se déroule
à chaque fois et de 10h à 17h et sans
rendez-vous 300 personnes en moyenne
pourront être vaccinés chaque jour dans
les yvelines l'île de loisirs du val de
seine est concerné ce week-end les 17 et
18 juillet une nouvelle opération est
prévue sur place les week-end du 14 et
15 août est également avec le site de
saint quentin en yvelines l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines qui
est concernée par cette opération le
variant delta va-t-il impacter la
reprise économique la question inquiète
les autorités
à moins d'un an après le déploiement du
plan en france relance 100 milliards
d'euros pour faire repartir le pays dans
cette enveloppe un plan de relance de 2
milliards d'euros également dédié à la
culture certains sites événement pure en
bénéficier et redémarrer leur activités
après de longs mois d'arrêt les
précisions de bixente mayence insisté
ban et de nicolas landry des aides
spécifiques à la culture ont été
déployées après le premier confinement
afin de subvenir au manque d entreprises
et organismes culturels
le collectif 12 lieux de création
culturelle située à mantes la jolie a pu
toucher sa part on est en relation et
plusieurs services au sein de la drac
direction régionale des affaires
culturelles donc le service théâtre et
le service dans ce qui dans le cadre du
des fonds
de la drac du plan de relance nous ont
déjà attribué un peu d'argent notamment
le service chorégraphique
vingt mille euros ont été distribués au
collectif en mai 2021 pour l'aider dans
ses missions de création de spectacles
avec les artistes et d'organisation
d'ateliers de danse et de théâtre avec
les enfants notamment
c'est notre capacité à nous de
d'intervenir en coproduction un peu plus
avec les compagnies qu'on reçoit et qui
crée ici
nous on n'est pas un lieu très riche
donc elle a priori on a très peu
d'argent à m
dans les projets eux-mêmes là il se
trouve qu'avec le plan de relance on va
soit directement quand c'est nous qui
payons les artistes soit avec les
compagnies qui sont là on va forcément
heureux et abondé sur les budgets de
création des aides qui reste limité pour
certains artistes dans une période où le
milieu culturel n'est pas uniquement
impacté par l'aspect financier
en terme économique je pense que ça on
peut toujours faire mieux
cela dit je pense que la partie qui a
été le plus difficile à gérer c'est
vraiment le fait d'être toujours pris en
compte à la dernière minute par rapport
à tous les plans qui ont été faits et du
coup d'avoir toujours des informations
très tard qui nous a pas permis de
s'organiser comme on aurait préféré pour
la librairie du pavé du canal à montigny
le bretonneux les fonds du plan de
relance ont été perçus en octobre
dernier le plan relance ça a été une
participation du centre national du
livre à nos charges fixes durant le
premier confinement c'est un versement
qui est intervenue à l'automne 2020 et
ça prenait en charge le voyait une
participation à nos loyers durant ce
premier compliment qui a été très dur
pour nous et où les commerces étaient
fermés la librairie comme le collectif
12 sont tous deux dans l'attenté d'une
nouvelle aide
la première pour permettre sa
modernisation le second pour pouvoir
assurer l'ouverture tout au long de
l'été et pour parler du plan france
relancé son déploiement dans les
yvelines avec moi en plateau jeune ben
c'est dire ah bon score vous êtes sous
préfète g secrétaire générale adjointe
en charge du développement économique et
de la cohésion des territoires la
préfecture des yvelines alors vous êtes
plus particulièrement sur ce dossier du
plan france relance dans les yvelines
vous fait déjà réagir aux sujets que
l'on vient de voir ensemble
avec un volet qui est peut-être moins
connu celui de l'aide à la culture dans
ce plan en france relance mais c'est un
volet non moins importants de ce plan je
remercie de m'inviter effectivement pour
faire le bilan de ce plan de relance qui
a été déployée aujourd'hui depuis un an
depuis le mois de septembre dernier
effectivement le volet culturel et on le
sait tous les acteurs de la culture ont
subi de plein fouet les impacts de cette
crise le plan france relance à un volet
culturel il 2000 il ya deux milliards
d'euros ont été consentis aux acteurs
culturels dans ce cadre différents
dispositifs différentes priorités ont
été identifiées et c'est exactement ce
qu'on vient de voir ici les priorités 3
et 4 sont des priorités de création au
gem créa pardon de soutien aux jeunes
créateurs est la priorité numéro 4 et la
consolidation des filières culturelles
stratégique donc comment aujourd'hui à
la fois répondre aux urgences du moment
qu'ils sont immédiates du le soutien en
librairie par exemple dans les yvelines
c18 librairie qui ont été soutenus à
hauteur de 270 mille euros et commet
également préparer l'avenir avec ces
filières culturelles stratégiques dont
le plan filière livre et c'est pour ça
qu'il ya ces librairies qui ont été
soutenues dans les yvelines donc soutien
au volet culturel également au volet
patrimoine avec un monument dans les
imiter a été aussi grandement soutenue
par ce plan france relancé le château de
versailles exactement alors on a eu
quand même une grande chance dans notre
département c'est d'être doté justement
de 2,2 dans le secteur du patrimoine
artistique de monuments particulièrement
importants dont le château de versailles
qui a bénéficié d'un soutien de 83
millions d'euros donc ça un soutien très
fort qui peut se comprendre parce qu'il
ya une perte de recettes très importante
avec 35 millions d'euros en moins
puisque habituellement le château de
versailles reçoit 7 millions de
visiteurs internationaux par an et qui
n'en a reçu que 1 millions cette année
ça c'est pour le volet culturel le volet
patrimoine parlons maintenant plus
généralement de ce plan france relance
je le disais 100 milliards d'euros pour
redémarrer l'économie française après le
début de cette crise sanitaire
le plan a été annoncé en septembre ça
fait désormais 1
moins d'un an qu'il a été lancé est ce
que dans les yvelines ça a été déployée
tout de suite après les annonces du
gouvernement ça a mis un peu de temps à
se mettre en place dans les halls et
comme je vous le disais on a eu de la
chance parce qu'on a une bonne
appropriation dans le département des
yvelines des différentes mesures du plan
france roland je pense qu'il ya une
vraie mobilisation des acteurs de l'état
des acteurs aussi locaux des
collectivités locales nous à la
préfecture des yvelines
on a mis en place des webinaires qui ont
vocation justement à informer les
acteurs culturels les acteurs de
l'économie sociale et solidaire des
différents mesures du plan de relance
qui sont effectivement circonscrite dans
le temps donc il faut être très réactif
c'est l'enjeu du plan de relance il ya
des mesures de protection puissante des
entreprises les peler les prêts garantis
par l'état les aide justement pour la
les les financements d'activité
partielle pardon et puis il ya aussi ce
plan de relance qui pousse à se sent
investie à investir dans l'avenir
aujourd'hui dans les yvelines où on a
plus de 235 millions d'euros qui ont été
qui ont été engagées à date
donc on a une ligne sur une bonne
dynamique dont combien d'entreprises
bonjour à peu près 100 92 entreprises à
date
encore une fois ce sont vraiment des
chiffres très très récent on a une bonne
appropriation juste pour avoir quelques
chiffres en tête ce plan de relance il
est basé sur trois axes un volet
compétitivité un volet transition
écologique et un volet quoi ils ont
social sur le volet compétitivité c'est
35 4 millions d'euros qui ont été
déployés dans les yvelines pour aider
les entreprises qui souhaitent se
relocaliser dans les yvelines
typiquement ça a été le cas de
l'entreprise car matt et r captif car
matifiant plus l'actualité on a appris
aujourd'hui que il avait eu
l'autorisation pour une première
implantation de leur coeur artificiel
aux etats unis c'est l'actualité qui est
du jour et de coûts humains n'ont qu'à
la 20e de la trappe ces deux là car matt
a été soutenu à hauteur d'homme
millions d'euros pour son activité
justement de l'innovation technologique
et r captifs c'est pour son activité de
relocalisation dans les yvelines
c'est pour vous c'était pour vous donner
un exemple sur l'aspect compétitivité
sur l'aspect transition écologique on
est à 100,9 millions d'euros donc c'est
vraiment le plus gros pôle dans le plan
de relance parce que c'est un pôle qui
peut à la fois répondre aux urgences du
moment mais aussi mettre les
collectivités territoriales les
entreprises sur une stratégie de
transition écologique
donc ça a été le cas typiquement avec ma
prime rénove c'est un dispositif qui a
beaucoup été sollicité et qui dans les
yvelines a permis de répondre à beaucoup
de sollicitations à la fois des
collectivités et des entreprises et avec
un effet de levier sur la commande
publique qui elle a beaucoup pâti dans
ce contexte de crise avec une baisse de
plus de 7% des investissements locaux
vous avez parlé des types de projets qui
pouvaient être soutenu les les exemples
également la dernière question voulez
vous posez les critères de sélection
comment sont sélectionnés justement et
bien telle ou telle entreprise pour
bénéficier de france relance
comment ça se passe alors juste avant de
répondre à cette question j'ai oublié un
axe très important et je ne voudrais pas
le maître c'est la cohésion des
territoires avec le plan un jeune une
solution qui est juste fondamental pour
nous on a pu grâce à ce plan et des
dix-huit mille jeunes dans le
département des yvelines on leur a
offert soit des solutions d'emplois soit
des solutions de formation grâce
justement à des subventionnements des
contrats aidés d alternance et des
apprentissages
voilà pour répondre à votre question lac
le critère numéro un est vraiment celui
de la réactivité
comme son nom l'indiqué le plan de
relance doit avoir un effet
contracyclique il faut réagir vite
donc quand les projets sont plutôt près
ficelé que ce soit pour les
collectivités territoriales qui étaient
déjà prêtes en fait et lolo la
temporalité du plan de relance était
intéressante puisqu'elle est venu
typiquement si on prend l'enjeu des
municipales est venu juste après les
mines
bâle donc ça peut aussi coïncidé avec un
projet de territoire donc les
collectivités qui avait déjà des projets
prêts ont pu les soumettre et ont été
retenus les entreprises
c'est exactement la même chose celle qui
était prête donc l'idée c'était de ne
pas saupoudrer de concentrer
l'intervention de l'état entre 80 et 90%
des financements pour vraiment faire en
sorte que cet effet de levier soit réel
sur les projets les plus près et surtout
ceux qui correspondent à ces trois axes
transition écologique compétitivité et
cohésion sociale via des appels à
projets ou des appels à manifestation
d'intérêt tous derrière des chevaux est
ce que de nouvelles entreprises pourront
en bénéficier ou c'est terminé non c'est
encore possible le plan de relance enfin
les différents appels à projets du plan
de relance court jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2022 et je profite de cette
audience pour rappeler que la préfecture
des yvelines organise des webinaires
justement à destination des acteurs de
l'économie sociale et solidaire de de la
culture mais pas que de tous les
secteurs en fait qui sont touchés pour
leur faire un focus sur les appels à
projets qui sont encore d'actualité
et aussi pour aussi les accompagner dans
le contexte de sortie de crise puisque
aujourd'hui on peut parler d'un contact
de sortie de crise à la rentrée au mois
de septembre
je donne rendez-vous justement aux
entreprises pour travailler notamment
sur les dispositifs d'accompagnement à
la sortie de crise indépendamment du
plan de relance notamment avec le
tribunal de commerce qui peut je le
rappelle aider les entreprises à éviter
des faillites
quand elles sont prises en temps et en
heure non pour avoir plus d'informations
rendez vous sur le site un tas de la
préfecture pour avoir toutes les
coordonnées alors on va passer yvelines
point gouv.fr le site internet de la
préfecture des yvelines pour avoir
toutes ces informations merci j'ai une
benne sedira d'être passé en plateau
pour parler de france relance et je
rappelle que vous êtes sous préfète
secrétaire générale adjointe en charge
du développement économique et de la
cohésion des territoires à la préfecture
des yvelines merci d'avoir été avec nous
[Musique]
direction saint cyr l'école à présent
avec une ville qui s'est transformé ces
dernières années la zac charles renard
est en passe de devenir un éco quartier
cette semaine la maire de la commune est
venu constater l'avancée des travaux
l'occasion pour nous de faire le point
sur les équipements à venir et c'est
avec bixente n'a rien senti steban les
chantiers de toutes parts sont en cours
dans la zac chars renard de saint cyr
l'école de nombreux immeubles sont
érigés dans cette ancienne zone
militaire afin de construire un nouvel
écoquartier c'est un écoquartier en
effet avec une zone 30 sur tout le
quartier
donc une zone partagée entre les piétons
les vélos et les voitures on a été
extrêmement pugnaces sur le nombre de
parkings dans les bâtiments justement
pour éviter les voitures en surface
l'objectif oui c'est des noues des
espaces de prairies est vraiment un
sentiment de vivre à la fois la ville à
la fois la campagne plusieurs grosses
infrastructures vont ils voir le jour
parmi elles le pôle sportif pierre
mazeaud 6000 mètres carrés sur trois
étages soit trois fois plus grand qu'un
gymnase classique de nombreuses salles
pourront recevoir des activités diverses
de la gymnastique aux sports de combat
axe principal du projet la salle
multisports de niveau régional étudié
pour accueillir à la fois un sport
d'intérieur et de l' escalade l'élément
phare vraiment c'est la structure
d'escaladé la structure artificielle
d'escaladé
c'est quelque chose qu'on n'a pas du
tout sur la ville de saint cyr
actuellement donc ça c'est vraiment un
point fort
il ya beaucoup d'attentes au niveau de
la ville 1 / sur cet espace de pratique
à une petite centaine de mètres de là un
autre grand chantier celui de la maison
des associations la maison des
associations 1 fait elle vient en
remplacement du centre c'est marc qui
était l'ancien centre des associations
qui était composé d'une
d'une ancienne demeure de m et puis deux
bâtiments qui au fur et à mesure des
années avaient été rajoutés sauf que les
bâtiments n'étaient pas pmr
était vieillissant d'une manufacture pas
pas très joyeuse voire même délabré la
maison des associations doit s'ouvrir à
partir du 15 septembre prochain
quant au pôle sportif pierre mazeaud
l'inauguration est prévue au moment du
forum des associations le 11 septembre
à noter que deux écoles sont également
en passe d'être achevés pour la rentrée
prochaine
une fois n'est pas coutume direction
ocana présent ou la région ile de france
est allée soutenir les films en
compétition à la 74e édition du célèbre
festival
au total vingt films ont reçu le soutien
de la région 22 millions d'euros au
total sont alloués chaque année au
cinéma et aux côtés des stars qui
défilent sur le tapis rouge jusqu'au 17
juillet la vice présidente en charge de
la culture s'est rendu sur la croisette
on écoute au micro d'eléonore sinoquet
de michael et demi d'euros ça fait
plaisir de reprendre une activité
culturelle concrète avec des projections
de films des rencontres de la chaleur
humaine avec après la période que guide
et puis en plus de voir que cette 74ème
édition a vu là un record puisque vingt
films ont été soutenus par la région ile
de france c'est de rencontrer des
professionnels du secteur d'affiner des
dispositifs existants d'en prévoir
d'autres parce que valérie pécresse
avait un programme à un programme
extrêmement ambitieux pour cette
nouvelle mandature donc la voyons vient
de rencontrer à la filière des
scénaristes avant l'été avec l'acide
d'anticiper même sur les prochaines
semaines parce que le cinéma est un
secteur qui ne se portent pas si bien
que ça qui a besoin d'une ambition sans
cesse renouvelée et je ne trouve pas
qu'actuellement un et apporte cette
ambition je n'ai pas eu de discours fort
donc c'est à la région de soutenir le
cinéma mais au delà du soutien d'avoir
une vraie ambition est de lui permettre
une meilleure rayonnance un festival de
cannes réussit c'est un festival
justement on a beaucoup de films
sélectionnés ce qui prouve que badigeon
à travailler qu'on n'a pas abandonné
qu'on a soutenu monsieur et qu'on a
soutenu concrètement et du coup ça a
permis de l'emploi a permis de la
rayonnante c'est ça leur permet surtout
d'être vu dans le plus beau festival du
mandat du sport dans ce journal ce
dimanche déjà la ville de chatou
accueillera la dernière étape du tour de
france direction les champs-elysées
cette semaine à mantes la jolie en
revanche est la ville a organisé les
championnats de france d'aviron une
compétition initialement prévu à vichy
mais celle ci a dû être délocalisé suite
à une rupture d'une vanne d'un barrage
est le club de l'aes monthey s'est donc
porté candidat pour cet événement le
reportage de mickaël millero dix jours
pour recevoir 3000 rameurs le club
d'aviron de mantes-la-jolie et remporte
son contre-la-montre en organisant la
dernière minute les championnats de
france
la structure blinoise a remplacé la
ville de vichy sur ces dates du 14 au 18
juillet on a fait bien entendu à la
volée
on était surtout une volonté de
permettre à tous les rameurs minimes
cadets et seniors de pouvoir pratiquer
leur sport et de rendre concret leur
leurs efforts de l'année tous les
entraînements qui ont été quand on était
mené et donc il fallait absolument
maintenir cette compétition au total une
centaine de clés venus des quatre coins
de la france a répondu présents sur ce
rendez vous dont cinq structures des
yvelines quatre championnats de france
étaient programmés pour la première fois
sur un même lieu pour les minimes cadets
et seniors c'est un très bon niveau
sportif certes il n'ya pas les athlètes
sélectionnés aux jeux olympiques
puisqu'ils sont déjà en préparation et
même pour certains déjà sur le point de
partir
à tokyo mais en tout cas ça reste
vraiment des épreuves d'un excellent
niveau
que ce soit en j 14 ans j 16 et a ainsi
que pour les seniors mantes-la-jolie va
organiser d'autres événements nationaux
d'ici la fin de l'année les 25 et 26
septembre les championnats de france
seniors et une coupe de france des
régions fin octobre est la fête
nationale se déroulait hier mercredi et
dans la nuit du 14 du 13 au 14 juillet
des incidents à déplorer dont celui ci
est le chef de la police municipale de
mantes-la-jolie renversé par un
chauffard les faits se sont produits
vers 2 heures du matin boulevard des
signes alors que le responsable quitte
les locaux de la police municipale il
est violemment heurté au niveau du pare
chocs
un acte qui semble délibéré et bien
heureusement il est rapidement prise en
charge par les pompiers et s'en sort
avec de légères blessures au dos le
chauffeur a pris la fuite et est
activement recherché son véhicule a été
retrouvé dans le quartier du val fourré
la fête nationale c'est aussi
traditionnellement le soir des bals et
feux d'artifice mais les conditions
météorologiques de ces derniers jours
ont modifié de nombreux programmes de
festivités si guyancourt voisins le
bretonneux et montigny le bretonneux ont
bien pu célébrer le 14 juillet elancourt
la verrière et maurepas ont dû se
résoudre à reporter leurs feux
d'artifice et dates évoquées pour le
moment le dernier week-end du mois
d'août pour reporter ce feu d'artifice
les propos recueillis par mélanie potier
il pleut beaucoup et qu'on a attendu
jusqu'à la dernière minute
on pensait pouvoir l'organiser pour
évidemment le bonheur de toutes les
familles mais la réalité nous a rappelés
à l'ordre et on a préféré leur porter
d'ici la rentrée ce sera la même
thématique de ce beau feu d'artifice
puisque je vais tacler et déjà préparé
avec de belles musiques avec de
magnifiques un magnifique spectacle de
son et lumière voilà qu'on retrouvera à
la rentrée septembre écoutez c'est la
rentrée des enfants c'est la rentrée des
familles dont
dès le retour des vacances soit en
propose de faire ça tous les trois pour
que ce moment sur vraiment convivial
avec des conditions climatiques
favorables
le traditionnel défilé lui a bien eu
lieu sur les champs elysées 97 appareils
ont survolé le ciel de paris pour le
défilé aérien et les avions de la
patrouille de france de la sécurité
civile et les hélicoptères sont partis
de la base de vélizy-villacoublay
nicolas landry a pu se glisser dans les
coulisses de ce défilé dans les yvelines
c'est le dernier numéro de notre dossier
consacré au 14 juillet ils viennent de
terminer leur mission du jour
l'ouverture du défilé aérien du 14
juillet comme chaque année les neuf
pilotes de la patrouille de france lâche
la fumée tricolore au dessus des champs
elysées
une édition 2021 au départ de la base
censée de vélizy villacoublay d'où la
patrouille de france a décollé à 10
heures précises
bon super voilà bien ça s'est bien passé
météo était plutôt bonne finalement et
on est passé à l'heure à trois secondes
à trois secondes de téhéran travail
visibilité puis des plafonds net ça
s'est déroulé comme prévu formation le
timing la météo était bonne c'était
parfait toujours un grand honneur et une
grande satisfaction que direct le défilé
sur le 14 juillet d'ouvrir surtout le
défilé du 14 juillet pour cette édition
la paf arborer des dérives avec la tête
d'antoine de saint-exupéry un hommage
aux 75 ans de la publication du petit
prince directement sur les avions des
alphajet scrutées par les mécaniciens de
la patrouille de france
ils sont une quarantaine comme le
sergent chef jérémie l'entretien de
l'avion m'assurer qu'il ait pas de
dégâts pendant le vol
par exemple une prison at il avec un
oiseau je me dirai qui et pas de fuite
hydraulique
de particulier je regardais le motard
oui effectivement pour mon souhait qui a
pas eu de fuite d'huile que les niveaux
surfait autres appareils au départ de la
base de vélizy-villacoublay les
hélicoptères fennec de l'armée de l'air
et de l'espace
des aéronefs utilisés sur plusieurs
missions polyvalente
ils étaient deux à défiler au dessus des
champs elysées l'un d'entre eux était
piloté par le capitaine armes
c'est un moment de convivialité pour
nous hélicoptériste de l'armée de l'air
et de l'espace pour se retrouver et
après en plus de ça effectivement voilà
c'est tout un symbole c'est le défilé du
14 juillet voilà passer montré qu'on est
fiers de notre nation montrer les
compétences qu'on a deux autres
hélicoptères fennec était dans le ciel
de paris le 14 juillet leur mission
assurer la défense aérienne du défilé en
formant une bulle de protection autour
du site
objectif éviter l'intrusion d'aéronefs
dans le périmètre
on va s'approcher justement de l'aéronef
et on va lui faire un message en fait on
a un panneau lumineux où on peut écrire
des messages sans relâche pas être en
communication avec donc on lui demande m
on met une fréquence radio on lui
demande de se mettre à cette fréquence
pour pouvoir communiquer explique
souvent défaillant on a des aéronefs qui
ont des problèmes radio donc ils ont
plus de communication du tout donc par
exemple on peut lui m suivez nous donc
faut au milieu ou suivez nous hélas à
partir de ce moment là on va l'emmener
sur un petit aérodrome ou qui puisse
s'opposer sur une main au total 97
avions et hélicoptères ont participé au
défilé du 14 juillet 2021
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
votre fidélité le cetud journal prend
désormais ses quartiers d'été retour de
l'information locale en direct à partir
de septembre
mais d'ici là ne vous inquiétez pas atv
78 sera bien là pour vous proposer au
quotidien des reportages avoir sur notre
chaîne aux réseaux sociaux notre site
internet et notre application mobile
j'ai été très heureux de vous
accompagner tout au long de cette saison
une année à bien sûr marquer une
nouvelle fois par la crise sanitaire à
un grand merci à toute l'équipe de tv 78
qui a rendu possible c'est plus de 160
édition du journal journalistes bien sûr
mais aussi monteur community manager
webmaster infographiste et une pensée
particulière pour eléonore sinoquet et
astrid bergère qui a s'en vont voguer
vers de nouvelles aventures très bel été
à tous restés prudents et bel été
et bonne soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]